hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
es gibt drei änderungen und zwar erstens
sind wir hier in einer entschuldigung
erstens sind wir hier gerade in einer
neuen map uns okay wir befinden uns hier
gerade in goes city bay viele meinten zu
mir ich hab jetzt mittlerweile so zehn
folgen single layer in den letzten
monaten gemacht ich sollte mal die neue
map die zweite sache ich war beim
friseur und ich mag es nicht so gern
wenn ich direkt vom versorgte sich eine
kapuze auf und ich dachte ich sähe gut
aus aber tue ich nicht und die dritte
sache ist man kann irgendwie
multiplikator mutanten goats auswählen
darf ich zu beginn einfach mal die
tellian dinosaur gut ausgewählt ich weiß
aber nicht was mir das jetzt gebracht
hat ich habe mal wieder eine letzten
folge gesagt wir sollten ein paar sachen
schreiben die ich um minimal testen
sollen
immer diese scheiss raser alter da wurde
halt am meisten wirklich danach gefragt
sich einfach nein danach würde mich aber
ich mag es wird sehr stark bemängelt er
sich allzu lange in der alten welt war
deswegen gucken wir uns jetzt mal gold
city way hier an ich glaube ich hab erst
eine folge hilft dieser map hier gemacht
und die war sogar am handy aufgenommen
das ist die mit der goty schon wieder
los ich werde gerade geritten
was für ein scheiß also ich hab ja
wirklich nichts gegen diese neue map und
ist es unglaublich schön dass das ganze
so aussehen diesen strand statt aber das
muss echt nicht sein
das geht überhaupt mit ihren füßen da
vorne ab
das macht der typ da unten eigentlich
was geht bei ihm china ich hab echt
nichts gegen dich aber du nervst ja ich
habe spaß mit john teenager sieht
bereitet ihre arme auch schon so toll
aus weil es so viel spaß macht man jetzt
mal ohne spaß ich wollte eigentlich ein
paar experimente machen und jetzt habe
ich die ganze diesen georgina kann ich
die wie werde ich dir denn los vor allem
respekt die cool diese stadt ist was ist
mit den leuten hier los mögt ihr das die
ganze zeit auf der stelle zu sein selbst
wenn ich mich einfach fallen lasse ist
georgina meine fresse verpiss dich von
mir ich will nicht von dir gerissen
werden das spiele ich einmal eine neue
map in gold und wird noch von sonne wie
werde ich dir denn los was passiert wenn
ich einfach mal guckt die auch nicht um
nicht rum exportiert alles und georgina
diesem app ist eindeutig nicht geheuer
was die menschen angeht
was ist los hier bei allem respekt ich
finds ultra knife dass man in der app
alles mögliche machen kann
okay die map ist doch komplette lkw
bitte rette mich in eine bessere welt
ohne diese behinderte georgina hier das
war nämlich eine sache die ich
eigentlich in der alten westen wollte
nämlich was ist wenn ich einen lkw mit
der zunge an lecke und er mich quasi
immer weiter zieht bis der lkw nachher
in diesem tunnel da oben rein fährt was
passiert mit georgina und mir wenn wir
in diesem tunnel reinkommen mit dem lkw
da sind wir wieder ich kann nicht sagen
ob ich die mädchen finde oder darum ist
ein helikopter es irgendwie möglich dass
sich diese georgina hier weg bekomme von
mir irgendwie doch kommt jetzt bin ich
noch im fahrstuhl wenn man denkt dass es
nicht mehr schlimmer kommen kann kommt
diese fahrstuhlmusik meine damen und
herren ich stehe auf dem fahrstuhl
wie bin ich hier hin gekommen ich will
raus
wie komme ich hier raus ich habe mich
jetzt verdammte scheiße response und
georgina ist noch immer auf mir drauf
man ich hab ja echt nichts gegen sie
aber ich habe etwas gegen sie wo bin ich
hier gelandet ist etwas das ich gar
nicht ich versuche jetzt als letzten
versuch diese georgina in die vom
herunterzubekommen dem ich jetzt einfach
von hier oben runter springe verdammte
scheiße georgina das kannst du nicht
überleben
ich bin raus ich bin raus ich wie die
wenig sinn macht dieses spiel